So Adam, where are we?
那么Adam，我们现在在哪？
I recorded this at the Ritz Carlton in Lower Manhattan. It's a black tie dinner. It was just a few weeks ago.
我在曼哈顿下城的丽思卡尔顿酒店录制这段内容。这是一场黑领结晚宴。就在几周前。
And you, by the way, are NPR's international business and economics correspondent?
顺便问一下，你是美国国家公共电台（NPR）的国际商业和经济记者？
That's right. I was there for my job. They're giving out awards for all these financial securities, including the one that nearly brought down the global financial system in the whole sub-prime mortgage crisis.
没错。我是因为工作在那里的。他们正在给各种金融证券颁奖，其中包括那个在次贷危机中几乎摧毁了全球金融体系的家伙。
At this time, I'd like to ask all of our stars to please assemble over here on the left side of the stage--
现在，我想请我们所有的明星到舞台左侧集合——
This guy is a legend. He's a granddaddy of our industry.
这家伙是个传奇。他是我们行业的教父。
I'm sitting at this dinner with Jim Finkel. He's kind of nervous, because he's up for CDO of the year for the CDO he created, Monterey. Now, the CDO, that's what we're talking about. That's the financial instrument that was central to this global credit crisis we're in.
我和Jim Finkel坐在这场晚宴上。他有点紧张，因为他凭借自己创造的CDO（债务抵押债券）——“蒙特雷”（Monterey），入围了年度CDO奖。对了，我们说的就是CDO。它正是我们所处的这场全球信贷危机的核心金融工具。
And they gave awards for this? These guys are giving each other awards for doing that?
他们居然给这个颁奖？这些人居然在互相颁奖，奖励这种行为？
Let me just say that they were aware that there's a certain irony, giving awards to the instrument that almost destroyed the world economy. And they did consider canceling this year. But it's been a really tough year. It's been really gloomy for them.
我只能说，他们意识到这有一定的讽刺意味，给这个几乎摧毁世界经济的工具颁奖。他们确实考虑过取消今年的颁奖。但这一年真的很艰难。对他们来说非常阴郁。
Honestly, I know this sounds-- I was really happy to see there were no major suicides, people weren't jumping off bridges, there weren't a lot of personal disasters.
老实说，我知道这听起来——我很高兴看到没有发生重大的自杀事件，人们没有跳桥，也没有出现很多个人的灾难。
Now that same week, a few days earlier, across the river in Brooklyn, I went to a completely different kind of gathering. It was not black tie. It was put on by the Neighborhood Assistance Corporation of America. It was people on the opposite side of the mortgage crisis, people facing foreclosure, trying to figure out how to keep their homes.
就在那周，几天前，在河对岸的布鲁克林，我参加了一个完全不同类型的聚会。那不是黑领结晚宴。它是由美国邻里援助公司（NACA）组织的。那里的人们处于抵押贷款危机的另一面，面临止赎，试图弄清楚如何保住他们的房子。
I met this one guy, Richard. He's a marine. He's this big guy, over six feet tall. And when he came back from Iraq a few years ago, he bought one of these fancy new mortgages with an adjustable rate. Recently his rate reset. It has gone up by more than $2,000 a month. And he has fallen behind on his payments.
我遇到了一个叫理查德的家伙。他是一名海军陆战队员。他是个大块头，身高超过六英尺。几年前他从伊拉克回来时，买了一款浮动利率的新型抵押贷款。最近他的利率重置了。每个月涨了2000多美元。他的还款已经逾期了。
It got to the point where-- one point, my son had $7,000 in a CD. And I had to break it. And I mean that really hurt, because I was saving that money for his college. I mean, I put $2,000 back. But it's like you can't have a future. They put you in a situation where, after a while, you're going to fail. It's hard.
到了这个地步——有一次，我儿子在存单（CD）里有7000美元。我不得不把它取出来。说实话，这真的很伤人，因为我一直在为他的大学存这笔钱。我存回了2000美元。但感觉就像你没有未来了。他们把你置于一种境地，过了一段时间，你必然会失败。这太难了。
Now, it's clear that these two groups are connected, Jim at his black tie dinner and Richard the marine. The sub-prime crisis has connected them.
现在很清楚，这两群人是相互关联的，Jim在黑领结晚宴上，以及海军陆战队员理查德。次贷危机将他们联系在了一起。
Right, and I know that, basically, this is what sent you and one of the producers of our show, Alex Blumberg, on a big reporting mission these past few months. You saw that, that there is this long chain of people that starts with these Wall Street guys and ends with people who stand to lose their houses. And all along that chain there were bankers, and brokers, and investors, and homeowners. And everybody along the chain kind of deluded themselves, thinking they could throw out the old rules of banking.
没错，我知道这基本上就是让你和我们节目的制片人之一Alex Blumberg在过去几个月里执行一项重大报道任务的原因。你看到了，有一条长长的人链，从华尔街那些人开始，一直到面临失去房子的人结束。在这条链条上，有银行家、经纪人、投资者和房主。链条上的每个人都在某种程度上欺骗了自己，认为他们可以抛弃旧的银行规则。
Right, in all the coverage of this, we hadn't heard that much from the people all along the chain. We wanted to know, what were they thinking when they were doing all this? And why did they think it would work? And simply, how did it all work?
对，在对此进行的所有报道中，我们还没有听到太多来自链条上各方人士的声音。我们想知道，他们在做这一切时在想什么？为什么他们认为这会行得通？简单地说，这一切到底是如何运作的？
So, this is what we're devoting our program to today. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. And today's show is a special co-production we're doing with NPR News, your place of employment, Adam.
所以，这就是我们今天节目要专注的内容。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目是我们与NPR新闻部的特别合作，也就是你工作的地方，Adam。
Very proudly so.
对此我感到非常自豪。
You and Alex Blumberg are going to be explaining step-by-step how this all worked. And we will meet some of the people who created this economic disaster. And so let me turn the show over to the two of you, which is great for me, because I've pretty much lost my voice anyway. And Alex Blumberg will kick things off.
你和Alex Blumberg将一步步解释这一切是如何运作的。我们将见到一些创造了这场经济灾难的人。所以让我把节目交给你们两位，这对我来说很好，因为反正我的嗓子也差不多哑了。Alex Blumberg开始吧。
The thing that got me interested in all this was something called a NINA loan. Back when the housing crisis was still a housing bubble, a guy on the phone told me that a NINA loan stands for no income no asset. As in, someone will lend you a bunch of money without first checking to see if you have any income or any assets.
让我对这一切产生兴趣的是一种叫做NINA贷款的东西。早在房地产危机还是房地产泡沫的时候，电话那头的一个人告诉我，NINA贷款代表“无收入、无资产”（no income no asset）。也就是说，有人会借给你一大笔钱，而不需要先核实你是否有任何收入或资产。
And it was an official loan product, like you could walk into a mortgage broker's office and they would say, well, we can give you a 30 year fixed rate, or we could put you in a NINA. He said there were lots of loans like this, where the bank didn't actually check your income, which I found confusing.
这是一种官方贷款产品，就像你可以走进抵押贷款经纪人的办公室，他们会说，嗯，我们可以给你一个30年期固定利率，或者我们可以给你办理一个NINA。他说有很多这样的贷款，银行实际上并不核实你的收入，我觉得这很让人困惑。
And it turns out even the people who got them found them confusing. For example, a guy I met named Clarence Nathan. He worked three part-time, not very steady jobs, and made a total of $45,000 a year, roughly. He got himself into trouble and needed money. So he took out a loan against his house, a big one.
事实证明，即使是获得贷款的人也觉得很困惑。例如，我遇到的一个叫Clarence Nathan的人。他做了三份兼职工作，工作不太稳定，总收入大约一年45000美元。他陷入了困境，需要钱。所以他以房子为抵押贷了一笔款，一笔大额贷款。
Call it $540,000 for round figures.
取个整数，54万美元。
You basically borrowed $540,000 from the bank, and they didn't check your income?
你基本上从银行借了54万美元，而他们没有核实你的收入？
It's a no income verification loan. They don't call me up and say, how much money? They don't do that. I mean it's almost like you pass a guy in the street, and you say, will you lend me $540,000? He says, well what do you do? Hey, I got a job. OK.
这是一个无收入核实贷款。他们不会打电话给我问：你赚多少钱？他们不会那样做。我的意思是，这几乎就像你在街上路过一个人，你说，你能借我54万美元吗？他说，好吧，你是做什么的？嘿，我有份工作。好的。
It seems as if it's that casual, even though there are a lot of papers that get filled out and stuff flies all over with the faxes and the emails, and all like that. Essentially, that's the process.
看起来好像就是那么随意，尽管填了很多表格，传真和邮件满天飞，诸如此类。本质上，这就是流程。
Would you have loaned you the money?
你会借钱给自己吗？
I wouldn't have loaned me the money. And nobody that I know would have loaned me the money. I mean, I know guys who are criminals that wouldn't lend me that money, and they'd break your kneecaps. So [LAUGHING] yeah, I don't know why the bank did it. I'm serious. $540,000, a person with bad credit.
我不会借钱给自己。而且我认识的人里也没有人会借钱给我。我的意思是，我认识的罪犯都不会借给我那笔钱，他们会打断你的膝盖骨。所以（笑）是的，我不知道银行为什么要这么做。我是认真的。54万美元，一个信用记录很差的人。
As it turns out, Clarence's friends, acquaintances and shadowy criminal contacts would have been right not to lend him the money. By the time I talked to him, Clarence hadn't made a payment in almost a year, and his house was in the process of foreclosure.
事实证明，Clarence的朋友、熟人和那些阴暗的犯罪分子如果拒绝借钱给他，那是正确的。到我跟他交谈时，Clarence已经近一年没有付款了，他的房子正处于止赎过程中。
And stories like this have been in the news for months. And they often feature an innocent homeowner who was duped by a lying, greedy mortgage banker. Or if you're more of a Wall Street Journal editorial page type, an innocent mortgage banker who was duped by lying, greedy homeowner. And no doubt, both categories exist. But Clarence's case is more nuanced, and much more common.
像这样的故事几个月来一直出现在新闻中。它们通常以一个被撒谎、贪婪的抵押贷款银行家欺骗的天真房主为主角。或者，如果你更倾向于《华尔街日报》编辑部那种视角，就是一个被撒谎、贪婪的房主欺骗的天真抵押贷款银行家。毫无疑问，这两类人确实都存在。但Clarence的案例更微妙，也更普遍。
Nobody came and told me a lie, and told me a story, and said, oh, just close your eyes, and all your problems will go away. That wasn't the situation. The situation was that I needed the money. And I'm not trying to absolve myself of anything.
没有人来跟我撒谎，讲故事，说，噢，闭上眼睛，你所有的问题都会消失。不是这种情况。情况是我需要那笔钱。我并没有试图为自己开脱什么。
I had a situation. And I thought that I could do this, and then get out of it within six to nine months. The six to nine month plan didn't work, so I'm stuck. But if somebody had told me, you couldn't borrow the money, I probably would have had to do something else more drastic and dramatic, and not be in this situation now. The bank made an imprudent loan. I made an imprudent loan. So the bank and I are partners in this deal.
我遇到了一个情况。我以为我可以做到这一点，然后在六到九个月内脱身。那个六到九个月的计划没奏效，所以我被困住了。但如果有人告诉我，你借不到这笔钱，我可能不得不做些更极端、更戏剧性的事情，而不是现在处于这种境地。银行发放了轻率的贷款。我申请了轻率的贷款。所以银行和我在这笔交易中是合伙人。
This imprudent partnership is new. And it's at the heart of the current housing crisis. For most of the history of banking, bankers wouldn't have loaned Clarence their money either. They didn't let people like Clarence near their money, in fact, people with part time employment and unpaid debts in their past.
这种轻率的伙伴关系是新的。它处于当前房地产危机的核心。在银行历史的大部分时间里，银行家也不会把钱借给Clarence。事实上，他们不会让像Clarence这样的人靠近他们的钱，那些有兼职工作和过去有未偿债务的人。
And then suddenly in the early 2000s, everything changed. Banking turned on its head and went out looking for partnerships with people like Clarence, loaning him half a million dollars without even checking to see if he had a job. What happened? Well to  help explain what happened here is my partner for the hour, Adam Davidson, the international business reporter for NPR. Hey, Adam.
然后突然在21世纪初，一切都变了。银行业彻底翻转，开始寻求与像Clarence这样的人建立伙伴关系，借给他50万美元，甚至不核实他是否有工作。发生了什么事？好吧，为了帮助解释发生了什么，这是我这一小时的搭档，NPR的国际商业记者Adam Davidson。嘿，Adam。
Hey, Alex.
嘿，Alex。
How's it going?
进展如何？
Good.
很好。
I got your title right, right?
我的头衔没说错吧？
Yes. Well, not exactly.
是的。嗯，不完全是。
Oh, what is it?
噢，那是什么？
It's international business and economics correspondent, actually.
其实是国际商业和经济通讯员。
Oh, sorry. It actually sounds more impressive. OK, so I guess the first thing we have to do is talk about the global pool of money, right?
噢，抱歉。听起来确实更令人印象深刻。好吧，我想我们首先要做的是谈谈全球资金池，对吧？
Right, the global pool of money, that's where our story begins. Most people don't think about it, but there's this huge pool of money out there, which is basically all the money the world is saving now-- insurance companies saving for a catastrophe, pension funds saving money for retirement, the Central Bank of England saving for whatever central banks save for, all the world's savings.
对，全球资金池，我们的故事就是从那里开始的。大多数人不会考虑它，但外面有一个巨大的资金池，基本上是全世界现在正在储蓄的所有资金——保险公司为灾难储蓄，养老基金为退休储蓄，英格兰中央银行为了中央银行储蓄的目的而储蓄，全世界的储蓄。
A lot of money, it's about 70 trillion.
很多钱，大约70万亿。
That's the head of capital market research at the International Monetary Fund, the place to go if you want to figure out how much money is in the world. So first off, how do we pronounce your name?
那是国际货币基金组织（IMF）资本市场研究主管，如果你想搞清楚世界上有多少钱，就去那里。首先，你的名字怎么读？
That will probably take, if this goes on air, probably, that will take two minutes at least. It's Pazarbasioglu, Ceyla Pazarbasioglu.
如果这要播出的话，这可能至少需要两分钟。是Pazarbasioglu，Ceyla Pazarbasioglu。
Ceyla Pazarbasioglu.
Ceyla Pazarbasioglu。
I'm very impressed.
我印象非常深刻。
And by the way, before you finance enthusiasts start writing any letters, we do know that $70 trillion technically refers to that subset of global savings called fixed income securities. Everyone else can just ignore what I just said. Let's put $70 trillion in perspective. Do this. Think about all the money that people spend everywhere in the world, everything you bought in the last year, all of it. Then add everything Bill Gates bought, and all the rice sold in China, and that fleet of planes Boeing just sold to South Korea, all the money spent in every country on Earth in a year. That is less than $70 trillion, less than the global pool of money.
顺便说一下，在你们金融发烧友开始写信之前，我们知道70万亿美元在技术上是指全球储蓄中被称为固定收益证券的那一部分。其他人可以忽略我刚才说的话。让我们把70万亿美元放在一个视角里来看。这样做。想想全世界人们消费的所有金钱，你去年买的所有东西，全部。然后加上Bill Gates买的一切，中国销售的所有大米，以及波音公司刚刚卖给韩国的那批飞机，地球上每个国家一年内消费的所有金钱。那还不到70万亿美元，不到全球资金池的总额。
Wow.
哇。
We're talking about a lot of money.
我们谈论的是很多钱。
That is a lot of money.
那确实是一大笔钱。
And that money comes along with armies of very nervous men and women watching over the pool of money. Investment managers, they don't want to lose a penny of that. They don't want to lose any of that money, and, even more so, they want to make it grow bigger. But to make it grow, they have to find something to invest in.
而这些钱伴随着大批非常紧张的男女在看管着这个资金池。投资经理，他们不想损失哪怕一分钱。他们不想损失任何这些钱，而且更重要的是，他们想让它增长。但为了让它增长，他们必须找到可以投资的东西。
So, most of modern history, what they did was they bought really safe and, frankly, really boring investments like treasuries and municipal bonds, boring things. But then, right before our story starts, something changed, something happened to that global pool of money.
所以，在现代历史的大部分时间里，他们所做的是购买非常安全且坦率地说非常无聊的投资，比如国债和市政债券，无聊的东西。但在我们的故事开始之前，发生了一些变化，全球资金池发生了一些事情。
This number doubled since 2000. In 2000 this was about $36 trillion.
这个数字自2000年以来翻了一番。在2000年，这大约是36万亿。
So it took several hundred years for the world to get to $36 trillion. And then it took six years to get another $36 trillion.
所以世界花了数百年的时间达到36万亿。然后只花了六年时间又增加了36万亿。
Yeah, there has been a very sharp increase.
是的，增长非常剧烈。
How does the world get twice as much money to invest? There are lots of things that happen. But the main headline is that all sorts of poor countries became kind of rich, making things like TVs and selling us oil. China, India, Abu Dhabi, Saudi Arabia made a lot of money and banked it.
世界如何获得两倍的投资资金？发生了很多事情。但主要的头条新闻是，各种各样的贫穷国家变得有点富有了，通过制造电视机和向我们出售石油。中国、印度、阿布扎比、沙特阿拉伯赚了很多钱并把它们存了起来。
China, for example, has over a $1 trillion in its central bank. And there are office buildings in Beijing filled with math geniuses, real math geniuses, looking for a place to invest it. And the world was not ready for all this new money. There is twice as much money looking for investments, but there are not twice as many good investments.
例如，中国中央银行有超过1万亿美元的储备。北京的办公大楼里坐满了数学天才，真正的数学天才，寻找投资的地方。而世界并没有为所有这些新钱做好准备。寻找投资的钱有两倍多，但好的投资机会却并没有增加两倍。
So that global army of investment managers was hungrier and twitchier than ever before. They all wanted the same thing, a nice, low-risk investment that paid some return. But then something happened that makes matters worse. At this precise moment, one guy took one of that army's favorite investments and made it a lot less attractive.
所以那支全球投资经理大军比以往任何时候都更饥渴、更神经质。他们都想要同样的东西，一种不错、低风险且能带来一定回报的投资。但接下来发生了一些让事情变得更糟的事情。就在这一刻，一个人拿走了那支大军最喜欢的投资之一，并让它变得不再那么有吸引力。
This is where we have to talk about Alan Greenspan, right?
这就是我们必须谈谈Alan Greenspan的地方，对吧？
Yeah, we have to.
是的，我们必须谈谈。
All right. But I'm just going to promise people that is the only time you're going to hear Alan Greenspan in this story. So bear with us.
好吧。但我向大家保证，这是你在本故事中最后一次听到Alan Greenspan。所以请耐心听我们讲下去。
All right. Here's one of his speeches that really drove that army of investment managers crazy.
好的。这是他真正让那支投资经理大军发疯的演讲之一。
The FOMC stands prepared to maintain a highly accommodative stance of policy for as long as needed to promote satisfactory economic performance.
联邦公开市场委员会准备保持高度宽松的政策立场，只要需要，以促进令人满意的经济表现。
You might not believe me, but that little statement, that is central banker's speak for, hey, global pool of money, screw you.
你可能不相信我，但那句声明，是中央银行家说的话，意思是：嘿，全球资金池，去你的。
Come on, that's not what he said.
得了吧，他不是那个意思。
It is. I speak central banker. Believe me, that's what he said. What he is technically saying is he's going to keep the fed funds rate-- that's when you hear, the fed interest rate-- at the absurdly low level of 1%.
就是。我说的是中央银行语言。相信我，他就是这个意思。他从技术上讲是在说，他要保持联邦基金利率——也就是你听到的那个联邦利率——处于1%的荒谬低水平。
And that sends a message to every investor in the world, you are not going to make any money at all on US Treasury bonds for a very long time. Go somewhere else. We can't help you.
这给全世界的投资者传达了一个信息：在很长一段时间内，你通过美国国债根本赚不到钱。去别处吧。我们帮不了你。
And so the global pool of money-- which does speak central banker. They understood what he was saying-- they looked around for some low-risk high-return investment. And among the many things they put their money into, there was this one thing that they fell in love with. To get it, they called Wall Street, a guy like this.
所以全球资金池——它们确实说中央银行语言。他们听懂了他的意思——他们四处寻找一些低风险、高回报的投资。在他们投入资金的众多事物中，有一样东西让他们爱不释手。为了得到它，他们致电华尔街，致电像这样的人。
My name is Mike Francis. During the beginning of the mortgage implosion, I was an employee, executive director at Morgan Stanley on the residential mortgage trading desk.
我叫Mike Francis。在抵押贷款内爆初期，我是摩根士丹利住宅抵押贷款交易台的一名员工、执行董事。
Mike was one link in a chain that connected the global pool of money to its new favorite investment, residential mortgages, the US housing market, and guys like Clarence Nathan. Think how attractive a mortgage loan is to that $70 trillion pool of money.
Mike是连接全球资金池及其最喜欢的新投资——住宅抵押贷款、美国房地产市场以及像Clarence Nathan这样的人——的一环。想想看，对于那70万亿美元的资金池来说，抵押贷款有多大的吸引力。
Remember, they're desperate to get any kind of interest return. They want to beat that miserable 1% interest Greenspan is offering them. And here are these homeowners paying 5%, 9% to borrow money from some bank. So what if the global pool could get in on that action?
记住，他们迫切想要获得任何形式的利息回报。他们想要击败Greenspan提供给他们的那个可怜的1%利率。而这里有房主支付5%、9%的利息从某家银行借钱。如果全球资金池能参与进来会怎样？
There are problems. Individual mortgages are too big a hassle for the global pool of money. They don't want to get mixed up with actual people, and their catastrophic health problems, and their divorces, and all the reasons that might stop them from paying their mortgages. So what Mike and his peers on Wall Street did, was to figure out a way to give the global pool of money all the benefits of a mortgage-- basically higher yield-- without all the hassle and risk.
问题在于，单笔抵押贷款对全球资金池来说太麻烦了。他们不想与真实的人打交道，处理他们灾难性的健康问题、离婚，以及所有可能导致他们停止偿还抵押贷款的原因。所以Mike和他在华尔街的同行们所做的是，想出一种方法，让全球资金池获得抵押贷款的所有好处——基本上是更高的收益——而不需要所有的麻烦和风险。
So picture the whole chain. You have Clarence. He gets a mortgage from a broker. The broker sells the mortgage to a small bank. The small bank sells the mortgage to a guy like Mike at a big investment firm on Wall Street. Then Mike takes a few thousand mortgages he's bought this way, he puts them in one big pile.
所以想象一下整个链条。你有Clarence。他从经纪人那里获得抵押贷款。经纪人将抵押贷款卖给一家小银行。小银行将抵押贷款卖给华尔街大型投资公司的像Mike这样的家伙。然后Mike拿走他以这种方式买下的几千笔抵押贷款，把它们放在一个大堆里。
Now he's got thousands of mortgage checks coming to him every month. It's a huge monthly stream of money, which is expected to come in for the next 30 years, the life of a mortgage. And he then sells shares of that monthly income to investors. Those shares are called mortgage-backed securities. And the $70 trillion global pool of money loved them.
现在他每个月都有数千张抵押贷款支票汇入。这是一笔巨大的月度资金流，预计在未来30年内，也就是抵押贷款的期限内持续流入。然后他将该月度收入的份额出售给投资者。这些份额被称为抵押贷款支持证券（MBS）。而70万亿美元的全球资金池非常喜欢它们。
It was unbelievable. I mean, we almost couldn't produce enough to keep the appetite of our investors happy. More people wanted bonds than we could actually produce. That was our difficult task, was trying to produce enough.
令人难以置信。我的意思是，我们几乎无法生产足够多的产品来满足投资者。想要债券的人比我们实际能生产出来的要多。那是我们艰巨的任务，就是努力生产足够的产量。
They would call and say, we're looking for more fixed rate. What have you got? Do you have anything coming? What's going on? Tell us what you're trying to do. From our standpoint, it's like, there's a guy out there with a lot of money. And we have got to find a way to become his sole provider of bonds, of mortgage bonds, to fill his appetite. And his appetite's massive.
他们会打电话来说，我们正在寻找更多的固定利率产品。你们有什么？有什么新的进展吗？正在发生什么？告诉我们你们在尝试做什么。从我们的角度来看，就像是有个有很多钱的人在那里。我们必须找到办法成为他唯一的债券、抵押贷款债券提供商，以填补他的胃口。而他的胃口是巨大的。
The problem was, to make a mortgage-backed security, you needed mortgages. Lots of them. So for Mike Francis to satisfy this demand and take his quite hefty fee from the global pool of money, he needed to buy up as many mortgages as possible.
问题在于，要制作抵押贷款支持证券，你需要抵押贷款。大量的抵押贷款。所以为了满足这种需求并从全球资金池中收取相当可观的费用，Mike Francis需要尽可能多地买入抵押贷款。
And to do that, he called a guy one link below him on this mortgage-backed security chain, a guy named Mike Garner, who worked at the largest private mortgage bank in Nevada, called Silver State Mortgage. And to give you a sense of how fast this business was growing, Mike Garner got into the mortgage business straight from his previous job as a bartender.
为了做到这一点，他打电话给抵押贷款支持证券链条上比他低一环的家伙，一个叫Mike Garner的家伙，他在内华达州最大的私人抵押贷款银行工作，叫Silver State Mortgage。为了让你感受到这项业务增长得有多快，Mike Garner是从他上一份调酒师的工作直接进入抵押贷款行业的。
One of my regulars, he actually hired me from the bar. He just said he needed some guys, and if I was interested in working for him. And then we started talking about how much I made and that. He beat me. He beat what I was making, so. I didn't know anything about the mortgage business. I was as green as you could be.
我的常客之一，他实际上是从酒吧雇用了我。他说他需要一些人，问我是否有兴趣为他工作。然后我们开始谈论我赚多少钱等等。他开出的条件比我赚的要好，所以。我当时对抵押贷款行业一无所知。我菜得不能再菜了。
Mike Garner's job-- the guy in Nevada-- was to buy up individual mortgages, mainly from brokers, bundle 200 or 300 of them together, and then sell them up the chain to Wall Street, to guys like Mike Francis.
Mike Garner的工作——内华达州的那个家伙——是买入个人抵押贷款，主要是从经纪人那里买入，将200或300笔抵押贷款打包在一起，然后沿着链条卖给华尔街，卖给像Mike Francis这样的家伙。
There's just too many Mikes here.
这里的Mike实在太多了。
I know. So many Mikes. There is actually just two Mikes. There's Mike Francis, the guy on Wall Street, and Mike Garner, the guy we're talking about now.
我知道。太多的Mike了。其实只有两个Mike。有Mike Francis，华尔街的那位，还有Mike Garner，我们现在谈论的那位。
He's in Nevada.
他在内华达州。
He's in Nevada. Right. And in the beginning, he'd only buy mortgages that were pretty standard and pretty safe. Mortgages where people had come up with a down payment and proven that they had a steady income and money in the bank. And they sold so many of these mortgages that there came a point in 2003 where just about everybody who wanted a mortgage and was qualified to get one, had gotten one.
他在内华达州。没错。起初，他只会买那些相当标准、相当安全的抵押贷款。人们已经支付了首付，并证明他们有稳定的收入和银行存款的抵押贷款。他们卖出了这么多这样的抵押贷款，以至于在2003年出现了一个时间点，几乎每个想要贷款且有资格获得贷款的人都已经得到了贷款。
But the pool of money had just gotten started. They wanted more mortgage-backed securities. So Wall Street had to find more people to take out mortgages, which meant lending to people who never would have qualified before. And so Mike Garner in Nevada noticed that every month the guidelines were getting a little looser.
但资金池才刚刚开始。他们想要更多的抵押贷款支持证券。所以华尔街不得不找到更多的人来贷款，这意味着要贷给那些以前从未达到资格的人。所以内华达州的Mike Garner注意到，每个月的指导方针都在变得越来越宽松。
Something called a stated income verified asset loan came out, which meant that people didn't have to provide a paycheck stub or W-2 form to get a loan as they had in the past. They could simply state their income, as long as they showed that they had money in the bank.
出现了一种叫做“声明收入核实资产贷款”的东西，这意味着人们不需要提供工资单或W-2表格来获得贷款，就像过去那样。他们只需要声明自己的收入，只要证明他们银行里有钱就行。
The next guideline lower is just stated income, stated assets. That came out. So then you basically state what you make, and then you state what's in your bank account. They call and make sure that you work where you say you work. And then an accountant has to say that for your field, it is possible to make what you say you make. But they don't have to-- they don't say what you make. They just say, it's possible that he could make that.
下一个更低的指导方针是“声明收入，声明资产”。那也出来了。所以基本上你声明你赚多少，然后声明你银行账户里有多少。他们会打电话确认你确实在你说的地方工作。然后会计必须说，在你的领域，赚取你所说的数额是有可能的。但他们不需要——他们不需要说你具体赚多少。他们只是说，他赚这个数额是有可能的。
If you could stop there for one second, it's just so funny that instead of just asking the people to prove what they make, there is this sort of theater in place of like, you have to find an accountant to say, yes this person who is sitting right in front of me, and who could very easily provide a W-2 form-- but we're not asking for a W2 form-- but we do want this accountant to say that, yeah, that person, what they're saying is possible in some universe.
如果你能在那儿停一下，这太搞笑了，不用让人们证明他们赚多少，而是有这种表演来代替，你必须找一个会计说，是的，这个就坐在我面前的人，他很容易提供W-2表格——但我们并没有要求提供W-2表格——但我们要这个会计说，是的，那个人，他所说的话在某种宇宙中是有可能的。
And I mean, loan officers would have an accountant that they could call up and say, can you write a statement saying that a truck driver can make this much money, or whatever.
而且我的意思是，贷款官员会有他们可以打电话的会计，说，你能写一份声明，说卡车司机赚这么多钱是可以的，或者其他什么的。
Then the next one came along. And it was no income verified asset. So you don't have to tell the people what you do for a living. You don't have to tell the people what you do for work. All you have to do is state that you have a certain amount of money in your bank account. And then the next one that came out is just no income no asset. So you don't have to state anything. You just have to have a credit score and a pulse.
然后下一个出现了。是“无收入核实资产”。所以你不需要告诉人们你是做什么工作的。你不需要告诉人们你是做什么工作的。你所要做的只是声明你的银行账户里有一定数额的钱。然后下一个出来的是“无收入，无资产”。所以你不需要声明任何东西。你只需要有信用评分和心跳。
Actually that pulse thing, also optional, like this case in Ohio, where 23 dead people were approved for mortgages.
实际上那个心跳的东西也是可选的，就像俄亥俄州那个案例一样，23个死人被批准了抵押贷款。
An interesting fact here. Mike Garner's bank did not care all that much how risky these mortgages were. This was a new era. Banks did not have to hold on to these mortgages for 30 years like they used to. They didn't have to wait and see if they'd be paid back. Banks like Garner's would just own the mortgages for a month or two. And then they sold them on to Wall Street. And then Wall Street would sell them on to the global pool of money.
这里有一个有趣的事实。Mike Garner的银行并不太关心这些抵押贷款风险有多大。这是一个新时代。银行不再需要像过去那样持有这些抵押贷款30年。他们不需要等待看看是否会被偿还。像Garner这样的银行只会持有这些抵押贷款一个月或两个月。然后他们把它们卖给华尔街。然后华尔街再把它们卖给全球资金池。
Which is how we get half million dollar no income no asset loans.
这就是我们如何得到50万美元“无收入，无资产”贷款的原因。
--and loans to dead people. So there's this whole other thing going on as well. Housing prices were rising fast. I think we all remember that. Lots of people in the mortgage industry had this faith that housing prices in the US simply never go down.
——还有给死人的贷款。所以还有完全不同的事情在发生。房价上涨很快。我想我们都记得。抵押贷款行业的许多人有一种信念，即美国的房价根本不会下跌。
So from the bank's perspective, even if the worst happens and someone defaults, the bank would then own a house, which is now worth even more than what they gave out in the loan. So all Mike cared about was whether or not his customers, the Wall Street investment banks, would buy those mortgages from him.
所以从银行的角度来看，即使发生最坏的情况，有人违约，银行也会拥有一处房产，现在的价值甚至高于他们发放的贷款额。所以Mike所关心的只是他的客户，即华尔街投资银行，是否会从他那里购买那些抵押贷款。
And he was under pressure to approve more and more loans. Because other guys in his company-- the actual guys cruising strip malls all across Nevada buying mortgages from brokers-- their commission depended on selling more loans. And occasionally those guys would hear about some loan that some other mortgage company offered that they weren't allowed to offer. And they'd complain to Mike.
而且他承受着批准更多贷款的压力。因为他公司里的其他人——那些在内华达州各地的购物中心巡游，从经纪人那里购买抵押贷款的家伙们——他们的佣金取决于销售更多的贷款。偶尔那些人会听说其他抵押贷款公司提供的某些他们不允许提供的贷款。然后他们会向Mike抱怨。
Three of them would show up at your door first thing in the morning, and say, I lost 10 deals last week to Meritius Bank. And they've got this loan. Look at the guidelines for this loan. Is there any way we can do this, because we're losing deals left and right?
他们三个会在第一天早上出现在你的门口，说，我上周流失了10笔交易给Meritius银行。他们有这种贷款。看看这种贷款的准则。我们有什么办法能做吗，因为我们正在到处流失交易？
Either they would find out who they were selling it to, or I'd get on the phone and start calling all these street firms or Countrywide and say, would you buy this loan? And finally, you'd find out who's actually buying them and would say, yes.
要么他们会找出是谁在卖它，要么我会打电话开始给所有这些街头公司或Countrywide打电话，说，你们会买这笔贷款吗？最后，你会发现谁在真正购买它们，并会说，是的。
So like, Merrill Lynch would say no, and Goldman Sachs would say no, and then you'd finally hit on somebody, and they would be like, yeah, we'll buy that loan.
所以就像，美林证券会说不，高盛会说不，最后你终于碰到了某个人，他们会说，是的，我们买这笔贷款。
Yeah, and then once I got a hit, then I'd call the other people back and say, listen, Bear Stearns is buying this loan. And I would like to give you the opportunity to buy these loans too. And once one person buys them, usually all the rest follow suit.
是的，一旦我得到一个确切消息，我就会给其他人打电话说，听着，贝尔斯登正在买这笔贷款。我也想给你们机会购买这些贷款。一旦有人买了，通常其余的人都会效仿。
So, what were you thinking when you're turning around, and you're selling those to Wall Street? Were you ever thinking to yourself like, what are you guys doing?
那么，当你转过身，把这些卖给华尔街时，你在想什么？你有没有想过，你们这些人到底在做什么？
Yeah, and my boss had been in the business for 25 years. And he hated those loans. He hated them. And he used to rant and just say, it makes me sick to my stomach the kind of loans that we do. And he fought the owners and the sales force, tooth and neck, about these guidelines. And we got the same answer every time. Nope. Other people are offering it. We're going to offer it too. We're going to get more market share this way. House prices are booming. Everything's going to be good. And the company was just rolling in the cash. I mean, the owners and the production staff were just raking it in.
是的，我的老板在这个行业干了25年。他讨厌这些贷款。他恨透了它们。他过去常常咆哮，只说，我们做的这种贷款让我反胃。他和所有者以及销售团队，为这些准则争吵不休。我们每次得到的答案都是一样的。不。别人都在提供它。我们也要提供。我们想通过这种方式获得更多的市场份额。房价正在繁荣。一切都会好的。而公司简直是现金滚动。我的意思是，所有者和制作人员简直是大赚特赚。
At the height, I was making between $75,000 and $100,000 a month.
在最高峰时，我每个月赚75000到100000美元。
This is Glen Pizzolorusso, who was an area sales manager at an outfit called WMC Mortgage in upstate New York. And just to repeat, he said $75,000 to a $100,000 a month. That's over a $1 million a year. Glen was just out of college. His job was a lot like Mike Garner's. He's the same link in the chain. And Glen loved his job.
这是Glen Pizzolorusso，他曾是纽约州北部一家叫WMC Mortgage的公司区域销售经理。再说一遍，他说的是一个月75000到100000美元。那是一年超过100万美元。Glen刚从大学毕业。他的工作和Mike Garner很像。他是链条中相同的一环。Glen热爱他的工作。
What was that movie, Boiler Room ? Did you ever see that movie? That's what it was like. I mean, it was the coolest thing ever. Just cubicle, cubicle, cubicle for 150,000 square feet. The ceilings were probably 25, 30 feet ceilings. The elevator had this big graffiti painting on it that was awesome.
那部电影叫《锅炉房》？你看过那部电影吗？就是那种感觉。我的意思是，那是有史以来最酷的事情。仅仅是格子间，格子间，150000平方英尺。天花板可能是25、30英尺高。电梯上有那种很棒的涂鸦。
A graffiti painting, meaning like, that had been there since before you guys moved in? So they had not done any amenities to this place?
涂鸦，意思是，在你们搬进去之前就在那里了？所以他们没有在这个地方做任何便利设施？
No, it was just a big, open space. And it was awesome. We lived mortgage. That's what we did. That's all we did. All of us, we just lived it. This deal, that deal, what's going on here? How are we going to get this one funded? What's the problem with this one? I mean, you get there, and that's all everybody is talking about.
不，那只是一个大的开放空间。它太棒了。我们以抵押贷款为生。这就是我们所做的。这就是我们所做的全部。我们所有人，我们只是生活在其中。这笔交易，那笔交易，发生了什么？我们如何完成这一笔的资助？这一笔有什么问题？我的意思是，你到了那里，那就是每个人都在谈论的全部。
And when Glenn wasn't working, he was doing his next favorite thing, spending, preferably, in the company of-- and this is his term-- B-list celebrities.
当Glen不在工作时，他在做他第二件最喜欢的事，消费，最好是与——这是他的话——B级名人在一起。
We would roll up to Marquee at midnight, with a line 500 people deep out front. Walk right up to the door. Give me my table. We're sitting next to Tara Reid and a couple of her friends. Christina Aguilera was doing a-- whatever, I'm Christina Aguilera. I'm going to get up and sing. So Christina Aguilera and all her people are there.
我们会在午夜开车到Marquee，门口排着500人的长队。径直走向门口。给我我的桌子。我们坐在Tara Reid和她几个朋友旁边。Christina Aguilera正在做——无论如何，我是Christina Aguilera。我要起来唱歌。所以Christina Aguilera和她的人都在那里。
Who else was there? Cuba Gooding and that kid from Filthy Rich: Cattle Drive. What was that kid's name? Fabian [? Barabia. ?] We ordered, probably, three or four bottles of Cristal at $1,000 a bottle. They bring it out. They are walking through the crowd. They hold the bottles over their head. There is fire crackers and sparklers. The little cocktail waitresses, so you order four bottles of those, they're walking through the crowd of people. Everybody is like, whoa, who's the cool guys? Well, we were the cool guys. You know what I mean? They gave me a black card. This little card with my name on it. There's probably like 10 of them in existence. And that meant that I just spent way too much money there.
还有谁在那里？Cuba Gooding和那个来自《Filthy Rich: Cattle Drive》的孩子。那孩子叫什么名字？Fabian [? Barabia. ?]。我们点的大概是三四瓶水晶香槟，一瓶1000美元。他们拿出来。他们在人群中走动。他们把瓶子举过头顶。有鞭炮和烟火。那些小鸡尾酒女服务员，如果你点了四瓶，她们在人群中走动。每个人都像，哇，那是谁的酷哥？嗯，我们就是那些酷哥。你明白我的意思吗？他们给了我一张黑卡。这张带我名字的小卡片。存世的可能只有10张。这意味着我在那里花的钱太多了。
Glen had five cars, a $1.5 million vacation house in Connecticut, and a penthouse that he rented in Manhattan. And he made all this money making very large loans to very poor people with bad credit.
Glen有五辆车，在康涅狄格州有一座价值150万美元的度假屋，在曼哈顿租了一间顶层公寓。他赚的所有这些钱都是通过向信用记录很差的穷人提供非常大额的贷款获得的。
We looked at loans, these people didn't have a pot to piss in. I mean, they could barely make the car payment, and now we're giving them a $300,000 to $400,000 house.
我们看了那些贷款，这些人根本拿不出一个子儿。我的意思是，他们几乎付不起车贷，现在我们要给他们一套30万到40万美元的房子。
But Glen didn't worry about whether these loans were good either. That was someone else's problem. And this way of thinking thrived at every step of this mortgage security chain. A guy like Mike Francis from Morgan Stanley, he told me he bought loans, lots of loans, from Glen's company. And he knew in his gut that they were bad loans, like these NINA loans.
但Glen也不担心这些贷款是否是好贷款。那是别人的问题。而这种思维方式在抵押贷款证券链条的每一步都盛行。像摩根士丹利的Mike Francis那样的家伙，他告诉我他买了Glen公司的大量贷款。他凭直觉就知道它们是坏账，比如这些NINA贷款。
No income no asset loans, that's a liar's loan. We are telling you to lie to us, effectively. I mean, we're hoping you don't lie, but-- tell us what you make. Tell us what you have in the bank. But we're not going to actually verify it? We're setting you up to lie. Something about that transaction feels very wrong. It felt very wrong way back when. And I wish we had never done it. Unfortunately what happened, we did it because everybody else was doing it.
无收入无资产贷款，那是“骗子贷款”。我们实际上是在告诉你要对我们撒谎。我的意思是，我们希望你不撒谎，但——告诉我们你赚多少钱。告诉我们你在银行里有什么。但我们实际上不会核实？我们是在让你撒谎。关于那笔交易的某些东西感觉非常不对。早在当时就感觉非常不对。我希望我们从来没做过。不幸的是，事情发生了，我们做了，因为其他人都在做。
It's easy to ignore your gut fear when you're making a fortune in commissions. But Mike had other help in rationalizing what he was doing, technological help. Mike sat at a desk with six computer screens connected to millions of dollars worth of fancy analytic software designed by brilliant Ivy League graduates hired by his firm. And this software analyzed all the loans in all the pools that Mike bought and then sold. And the software, the data, didn't seem worried at all.
当你赚取巨额佣金时，很容易忽略内心的恐惧。但Mike有其他帮助来合理化他的所作所为，技术上的帮助。Mike坐在办公桌前，面前有六台电脑屏幕，连接着价值数百万美元的花哨分析软件，这些软件是由他公司雇佣的杰出的常春藤盟校毕业生设计的。这些软件分析了Mike买入然后卖出的所有池中的所有贷款。而软件，数据，看起来根本不担心。
All the data that we had to review, to look at, on loans that were in production, that were years old, was positive. They performed very well. All those factors, when you look at all the pieces and parts, and you say, well, a 90% no income loan three years ago is performing amazingly well. It has a little bit of risk. Instead of defaulting 1 and 1/2% of the time, it defaults 3 and 1/2% of the time. Well, that's not so bad. If I'm an investor buying that, if I get a little bit of additional return, I'm fine.
我们必须审查和查看的关于生产中贷款的所有数据，即使是几年前的数据，都是积极的。它们表现得非常好。所有这些因素，当你查看所有的部分时，你会说，好吧，三年前的90%的无收入贷款表现得非常棒。它有一点风险。它违约率不是1.5%，而是3.5%。嗯，这不算太坏。如果我是买那个的投资者，如果我能得到一点点额外的回报，我就没问题。
Wait, Alex, I want step in here, because this is a very important piece of tape. A big part of this whole story, the whole crisis, is that a lot of really smart people, people who knew better, fooled themselves with this data. It was the triumph of data over common sense. Can you play that tape again?
等等，Alex，我想介入这里，因为这是一段非常重要的录音。整个故事、整场危机的很大一部分是，很多真正聪明的人，那些知道更好的人，用这些数据愚弄了自己。这是数据战胜常识的胜利。你能再放一遍那段录音吗？
Yeah, sure. Here you go.
当然。给你。
All the data that we had to review, to look at, on loans that were in production, that were years old, was positive.
我们必须审查和查看的关于生产中贷款的所有数据，即使是几年前的数据，都是积极的。
As we now know, they were using the wrong data. They looked at the recent history of mortgages and saw that the foreclosure rate is generally below 2%. So they figured absolute worst-case scenario, the foreclosure rate might go to 8% or 10% or even 12%. But the problem with that is that there were all these new kinds of mortgages given out to people who never would have gotten them before. So the historical data was irrelevant. Some mortgage pools today are expected to go beyond 50% foreclosure rates.
正如我们现在所知，他们使用了错误的数据。他们看了抵押贷款的近期历史，发现止赎率通常低于2%。所以他们认为最坏的情况，止赎率可能会达到8%、10%甚至12%。但问题在于，有这么多新型的抵押贷款发放给以前从未获得过贷款的人。所以历史数据是不相关的。今天的一些抵押贷款池预计止赎率将超过50%。
To be fair, they knew there were risks. But investors have a system to assesses those risks. They have the special companies, credit rating agencies, Moody's, Standard & Poor's, Fitch. Their job, their main job, is to assess risk for Wall Street and the global pool of money.
公平地说，他们知道存在风险。但投资者有一套评估这些风险的系统。他们有这些专门的公司，信用评级机构，穆迪、标准普尔、惠誉。他们的工作，主要工作，是为华尔街和全球资金池评估风险。
They rate every kind of bond according to its risk. AAA is the safest. Then there is AA, A, all the way down to B and below. And that's all most investors look at that, that letter grade. They trust the credit rating agencies. And these agencies blessed most of these mortgage-backed securities, gave them AAA ratings, which means they were considered as safe as a US government bond.
他们根据风险对每种债券进行评级。AAA是最安全的。然后是AA，A，一直到B及以下。大多数投资者只看那个，那个字母等级。他们信任信用评级机构。这些机构批准了大多数这些抵押贷款支持证券，给了它们AAA评级，这意味着它们被认为像美国政府债券一样安全。
This was the magic of the whole system. You could take a pool of thousands of risky mortgages and create a security that was called, money good, as safe as any investment out there. At least that's what people thought. We now know that those agencies relied on the wrong data, that same historic data that had nothing to do with these new kinds of mortgages.
这就是整个系统的魔力所在。你可以拿一个由数千笔高风险抵押贷款组成的池子，创造出一种被称为“钱货两讫”、像任何投资一样安全的证券。至少人们是这么认为的。我们现在知道，这些机构依赖的是错误的数据，就是那些与这些新型抵押贷款毫无关系的同样的历史数据。
And then, things got even worse. The thing that took this problem and turned it into a crisis was something else that was new, something called a collateralized debt obligation, a CDO. And that brings us back to the guy we met at the awards dinner in the beginning, Jim Finkel.
然后，情况变得更糟。将这个问题转化为危机的事情是另一些新东西，叫做债务抵押债券（CDO）。这又把我们带回了我们在文章开头在颁奖晚宴上见到的那个人，Jim Finkel。
Well, we're heading to the trading floor of Dynamic Credit, where we have all of our mortgage and CDO analysts, our head trader, our CIO--
嗯，我们正前往Dynamic Credit的交易大厅，那里有我们所有的抵押贷款和CDO分析师，我们的首席交易员，我们的首席信息官——
Jim Finkel runs this CDO shop, Dynamic Credit. It takes up three modified apartments on the Upper East Side of Manhattan. The trading room is like a factory floor for CDOs. It's where they make the things. This is what it sounds like. [SILENCE]
Jim Finkel经营着这家CDO商店，Dynamic Credit。它占据了曼哈顿上东区三个经过改造的公寓。交易室就像CDO的工厂车间。这就是他们制造东西的地方。听起来是这样的。[沉默]
Maybe factory is the wrong term. But this is where he makes CDOs. But what is a CDO? He shows us on a computer screen.
也许工厂这个词用错了。但这就是他制造CDO的地方。但什么是CDO？他在电脑屏幕上向我们展示。
I'm going to show you-- here's our deal, Monterey.
我要给你看——这是我们的交易，“蒙特雷”（Monterey）。
To start with, every CDO has its own name. Finkel loves his country house in the Berkshires, so he always names CDOs after towns in western Mass, like Monterey.
首先，每个CDO都有自己的名字。Finkel热爱他在伯克希尔的乡村别墅，所以他总是用马萨诸塞州西部的城镇来命名CDO，比如“蒙特雷”。
Monterey CDO Limited, we had a 189 assets in Monterey.
蒙特雷CDO有限公司，我们在蒙特雷有189项资产。
So that's 189 pools?
所以那是189个池子？
--189 tranches of different mortgage-backed pools.
——189个不同抵押贷款池的分层。
Let's translate some of that. A mortgage-backed security, you remember, is a pool of thousands of different mortgages. These are all put together and divided into different slices. Jim used the word tranche. Tranche is just French for slice. Some of these slices are risky and some are not. OK, a CDO is a pool of these tranches, a pool of pools.
让我们翻译一下。抵押贷款支持证券，你记得，是数千笔不同抵押贷款的集合。所有这些被放在一起并分成不同的切片。Jim使用了“分层”（tranche）这个词。Tranche在法语中就是切片的意思。其中一些切片是有风险的，而另一些则不然。好的，CDO是这些分层的集合，池子的池子。
And Jim and most companies like his weren't buying the top rated tranches, the safest ones, the AAAs. They were buying the lower rated stuff, the high risk stuff. Jim's company bought tranches that came from Glen Pizzolorusso's company, the guy who hung out at nightclubs with B-list celebrities, the guy who said he was selling mortgages to people who didn't have a pot to piss in.
而Jim和像他这样的大多数公司并没有购买最高评级的分层，也就是最安全的那种，AAA级的。他们买的是评级较低的东西，高风险的东西。Jim的公司购买了来自Glen Pizzolorusso公司的分层，就是那个和B级名人混在夜总会的家伙，那个说他正在向连一个子儿都拿不出来的人出售抵押贷款的家伙。
There is another term the industry uses. This is not a joke. They call these lower rated tranches, toxic waste. They are so high risk, they're toxic.
行业里还有一个术语。这不是开玩笑。他们称这些评级较低的分层为“有毒垃圾”。它们风险太高了，它们是有毒的。
So basically Adam, a CDO is sort of a financial alchemy, right? Jim takes this toxic stuff, these low-rated high-risk tranches, puts them all together, re-tranches them, and presto. He has a CDO whose top tranche is rated AAA, rock solid, good as money. If this seems too good to be true to you, you're in good company. Guys like billionaire investor Warren Buffett said the very logic was ridiculous. But back in 2005, 2006, the global pool of money, they couldn't get enough of these things. And the CDO industry was facing the same pressures everyone else was at every other step of this chain, to loosen their standards, to make CDOs out of lower and lower rated tranches. This is Jim's partner, Tonko Gast.
所以基本上Adam，CDO是一种金融炼金术，对吧？Jim把这些有毒的东西，这些评级低、高风险的分层拿来，把它们全部放在一起，重新分层，然后瞧。他有一个CDO，其最高分层被评为AAA，坚如磐石，像钱一样好。如果这在你看来太好而不真实，那你并不孤单。像亿万富翁投资者Warren Buffett这样的家伙说这种逻辑简直荒谬。但在2005、2006年，全球资金池，他们对这些东西趋之若鹜。CDO行业面临着链条上每一步每个人都面临的同样压力，即降低标准，用评级越来越低的分层来制造CDO。这是Jim的合伙人Tonko Gast。
Actually, in 2005 already, we had an internal debate here, because there were two banks coming to us saying, why don't you do a deal with us, BBB securities, and you get paid $1 million in management fees per year? Very clear, just like that, in 2005.
实际上，早在2005年，我们内部就有一场辩论，因为有两家银行来找我们说，为什么你不和我们做一笔交易，BBB证券，你每年能得到100万美元的管理费？非常清楚，就像那样，在2005年。
And we declined those deals. We said that we just don't believe that those BBB RMBS assets are money-good. We don't think they are well underwritten. And we think if we do a CDO of those, that's going to blow up completely.
我们拒绝了那些交易。我们说我们只是不相信那些BBB RMBS资产是好的钱。我们认为它们承销得不好。我们认为如果我们用那些做CDO，它会完全炸掉。
We were a little early in '05 by not wanting to do those deals. And people were laughing at us, to be honest, to say, well, you're crazy. You're hurting your business. Why don't you want to make-- per deal, you could make $1 million a year.
我们2005年因为不想做那些交易而显得有点太早了。老实说，人们在嘲笑我们，说，嗯，你疯了。你在伤害你的生意。你为什么不想赚——每笔交易，你一年能赚100万美元。
Did someone do that deal?
有人做了那笔交易吗？
Absolutely. Everybody. Not everybody, but a lot of people did.
当然。每个人。不全是每个人，但很多人做了。
Coming up, how $5 million can get you into $100 million worth of trouble. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，500万美元如何让你陷入1亿美元的麻烦。稍后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
[MUSIC - "HARD TIMES" THE SEX-O-RAMA SOUNDTRACK]
[音乐 - "HARD TIMES" SEX-O-RAMA原声带]
Well, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And although I feel fine, I have lost my voice this week. Today's show, a special co-production with NPR News, a step-by-step look at what exactly happened during the sub-prime mortgage crisis. One of our producers, Alex Blumberg, co-reported this story with NPR reporter Adam Davidson. The story continues.
嗯，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。虽然我感觉很好，但我这周失去了声音。今天的节目，是与NPR新闻部的特别合作，一步步审视次贷危机期间到底发生了什么。我们的一位制片人Alex Blumberg与NPR记者Adam Davidson共同报道了这个故事。故事继续。
From 2003 to 2006, the housing market was in a classic speculative bubble. Home loans were easy to get. So more and more people were buying houses. The increased demand for houses caused the prices to increase. And the rising prices created even more demand, as people started to look at homes as investments, investments that never went down in value. And in 2003, 2004, 2005 they didn't.
从2003年到2006年，房地产市场处于经典的投机泡沫中。住房贷款很容易获得。所以越来越多的人在买房。对房屋需求的增加导致价格上涨。而上涨的价格创造了更多的需求，因为人们开始将房屋视为投资，一种价值永不下跌的投资。在2003、2004、2005年，它们确实没有下跌。
You could buy a house with no money down, turn around and sell it a year later for-- in some areas-- double what you paid. People who had never invested in real estate before started buying multiple properties as investments. There were even shows on TV about how to do it. Here's a promo.
你可以零首付买房，转手在一年后以——在某些地区——你支付价格两倍的价格卖出。以前从未投资过房地产的人开始购买多处房产作为投资。电视上甚至有关于如何做的节目。这是一个预告。
Get ready for an all new season of Flip This House .
准备好迎接全新的《Flip This House》季节。
This is A&E's Flip This House . Discovery had the cleverly titled, Flip That House . There were other ones-- Property Ladder , Designed to Sell . Bravo came late to the game, debuting their show, Flipping Out , in November of 2007, well after the bubble had already popped.
这是A&E的《Flip This House》。Discovery频道有名字巧妙的《Flip That House》。还有其他的——《Property Ladder》、《Designed to Sell》。Bravo频道入局较晚，在2007年11月才推出他们的节目《Flipping Out》，那时泡沫已经破裂很久了。
Those white boys from New Haven, going to flip that   kitchen. Flip This House premieres Saturday, March 31 at 9:00 on A&E.
那些来自纽黑文的白人男孩，要去翻修那个厨房。《Flip This House》将于3月31日星期六9点在A&E首播。
The problem was that even though housing prices were going through the roof, people weren't making any more money. From 2000 to 2007 the median household income stayed flat. And so the more prices rose, the more tenuous the whole thing became.
问题在于，即使房价涨破天际，人们的收入并没有增加。从2000年到2007年，家庭收入中位数保持平稳。因此，价格涨得越高，整个事情就变得越脆弱。
No matter how lax lending standards got, no matter how many exotic mortgage products were created to shoehorn people into homes they couldn't possibly afford, no matter what the mortgage machine tried, the people just couldn't swing it. By late 2006, the average home cost nearly four times what the average family made. Historically it was between two and three times.
无论贷款准则变得多么宽松，无论创造了多少异国情调的抵押贷款产品来把人们挤进他们根本负担不起的房子里，无论抵押贷款机器尝试了什么，人们就是无法应付。到2006年底，普通房屋的成本几乎是普通家庭收入的四倍。历史上是在两到三倍之间。
And mortgage lenders started to notice something they had almost never seen before. People would close on a house, sign all the papers, and then default on their very first payment. No loss of a job, no medical emergency, they were under water before they even started. And although no one could really hear it, that was probably the moment when one of the biggest speculative bubbles in American history popped.
抵押贷款机构开始注意到他们以前几乎从未见过的东西。人们会完成购房，签署所有文件，然后在第一次还款时违约。没有失业，没有医疗紧急情况，他们在开始之前就入不敷出了。虽然没有人能真正听到，但这可能就是美国历史上最大的投机泡沫之一破裂的时刻。
Strangely, the first people in the mortgage-backed security chain who noticed were the ones near the top, the people on Wall Street like Mike Francis. He can remember almost to the day.
奇怪的是，抵押贷款支持证券链条上最先注意到的人是顶端的人，也就是像Mike Francis这样华尔街的人。他几乎能记住确切日期。
It would be somewhere around Halloween of 2006. We started seeing our securities that were even six, seven, eight months old start to perform very, very poorly. We started to really dig into the details to figure out what was going on. And then you start seeing, wow, the property values have stopped increasing. Something is really turning around bad here. What do we do?
那应该是在2006年万圣节前后。我们开始看到我们的证券，甚至是六、七、八个月大的证券，表现开始非常、非常差。我们开始真正挖掘细节，搞清楚发生了什么。然后你开始看到，哇，房产价值停止增长了。这里的情况真的在恶化。我们该怎么办？
The problem was that once property values started going down, it set off a reverse chain reaction, the opposite of what had been happening in the bubble. As more people defaulted, more houses came on the market. With no buyers, prices went even further down. And as prices declined, Mike Francis cleared up a mystery. Remember, even though he didn't trust these NINA loans, the bonds he turned them into, they performed well. Well, there was a reason.
问题在于，一旦房产价值开始下跌，它引发了一种逆向链式反应，与泡沫中发生的情况相反。随着更多人违约，更多的房屋进入市场。没有买家，价格跌得更厉害。随着价格下跌，Mike Francis解开了一个谜。记住，即使他不信任这些NINA贷款，他把它们变成的债券，它们表现很好。嗯，有一个原因。
It's obvious that they performed well, now, because their property kept increasing in value. And over time, they could continue to take cash out of it, if they needed to, to pay the bill. In other words, they could take out another loan from the bank, against the value of their house, which because of the bubble was now worth more than they bought it for.
现在很明显它们表现得很好，因为他们的房产价值在持续增长。随着时间的推移，如果需要，他们可以继续从中提取现金来支付账单。换句话说，他们可以以房屋价值为抵押，从银行取出另一笔贷款，因为泡沫的原因，房屋现在的价值高于他们购买时的价格。
These loans, called home equity lines of credit, became very popular in the early to mid 2000s partly because they were easy to get, but partly because people needed them to continue making their original mortgage payments. To pay off their debts, they went into more debt.
这些被称为房屋净值信贷额度的贷款，在2000年代初中期变得非常流行，部分原因是它们很容易获得，但部分原因是人们需要它们来继续支付原来的抵押贷款。为了还债，他们陷入了更多的债务。
And in late 2006 early 2007-- as prices began their plunge and alarm was spreading across mortgage-backed securities desks all over Wall Street-- the people on Wall Street, like Mike Francis, started backing away from some of the riskiest mortgages that they would accept. Which had a devastating effect on the mortgage companies, which had proliferated to sell them loans, a devastating effect on people like Mike Garner, the mortgage banker in Nevada, for one simple reason.
在2006年底2007年初——随着价格开始暴跌，警报在华尔街各地的抵押贷款支持证券交易台蔓延——华尔街的人，比如Mike Francis，开始拒绝他们以前会接受的一些风险最高的抵押贷款。这对那些为了卖贷款而激增的抵押贷款公司产生了毁灭性的影响，对像内华达州的抵押贷款银行家Mike Garner这样的人产生了毁灭性的影响，原因很简单。
(SUBJECT) MIKE GARNER: All these mid-size companies like us, we're not using our own money to fund these loans.
（受访者）Mike Garner：所有这些像我们这样的中型公司，我们不是用自己的钱来资助这些贷款。
The way it worked was that a small bank, like Silver State Mortgage where Mike Garner worked, would borrow money from a big bank, say Citibank or Washington Mutual. Silver State would use this borrowed money to buy up a bunch of loans and then pay back the big bank once it sold the loans to Wall Street. Now these smaller banks were highly leveraged, in most cases 20:1. Meaning in Silver State's case, even though it had, say, only $5 million of its own dollars, it could borrow 20 times that, $100 million, to buy loans with. So in late 2006, Mike is busily at it-- borrowing, buying, selling, paying back, and borrowing again-- when the emails started coming.
它的运作方式是，像Mike Garner工作的Silver State Mortgage这样的小银行，会从花旗银行或华盛顿互惠银行这样的大银行借钱。Silver State会用这笔借来的钱买下一堆贷款，然后在卖给华尔街后偿还大银行。现在这些小银行的杠杆率很高，在大多数情况下是20:1。意味着在Silver State的情况下，即使它只有比如500万美元自己的钱，它也可以借20倍，即1亿美元来购买贷款。所以到2006年底，Mike正忙着——借钱、买入、卖出、还钱，然后再借——这时电子邮件开始来了。
We get an email from a street firm-- I don't know, just say Credit Suisse First Boston. It says, as of-- whatever date-- December 29, we are no longer buying a stated income loan with a FICO less than whatever. And the email would say, there will be no exceptions. Please do not call the pricing desk to make any exceptions for this for this, or whatever.
我们收到了一封来自街头公司的电子邮件——我不知道，就说是瑞士信贷第一波士顿。它说，截至——日期什么的——12月29日，我们不再购买FICO分数低于某某的声明收入贷款。电子邮件会说，不会有例外。请不要致电定价台对此做出任何例外，诸如此类。
So you just start flipping out, and say, wait a second. You can't just say that you're not going to buy this with no notice. Well, we're saying it. And there is no notice. So, then you start to scramble and get the stuff out the door as soon as you can.
所以你开始抓狂，说，等等。你不能就这样不打招呼就说你不买了。嗯，我们说了。而且没有任何通知。所以，你开始手忙脚乱，尽快把东西卖出去。
Because you've already been assembling a bunch of those loans with those characteristics in play somewhere, right?
因为你已经在某处组装了一堆具有那些特征的贷款了，对吧？
Yeah, you've got $20 million, or whatever the number is, sitting there. And you say, oh crap. Well, I had better get those out the door, because within a week of when one street firm says we're not going to buy these loans, you can pretty much expect to see the same email from all them. A lot of times you'll get it from two others the same day.
是的，你有2000万美元，或者数字是多少，坐在那里。你说，噢，该死。好吧，我最好尽快把它们处理掉，因为在一家街头公司说我们不买这些贷款的一周内，你基本上可以期待看到所有其他公司发出同样的电子邮件。很多时候你会同一天收到另外两家的邮件。
So you're scrambling to sell them. And you're just going off sheer relationships you have with these guys. Like, OK, I've still got $10 million of these. I know you're not buying them anymore, but you've got to. Come on, you can't just leave me like this. But there comes a point where-- well, there came a point where, basically, all of them just said, we're not buying anything.
所以你正在拼命卖掉它们。而你只是靠你和这些家伙纯粹的关系。比如，好吧，我还有1000万美元这些贷款。我知道你不再买了，但你必须买。来吧，你不能就这样把我留在这里。但有一个时间点——嗯，到了一个时间点，基本上，他们所有人都说，我们什么都不买。
For Mike and his company that meant that they'd borrowed tens of millions of dollars to buy loans that now they couldn't sell. And since they had very little of their own money-- just like the home buyers whose mortgages they purchased-- they had no choice but to default on their loan. Silver State Mortgage's nearly 600 employees were out of work quite suddenly.
对于Mike和他的公司来说，这意味着他们借了数千万美元买了现在卖不出去的贷款。而且由于他们几乎没有自己的钱——就像他们购买抵押贷款的购房者一样——他们别无选择，只能拖欠贷款。Silver State Mortgage近600名员工突然失业了。
It was February 14. The email went out and said, Silver State Mortgage might be going out of business, but-- It was something along these lines-- might be going out of business, but we think we can work something out. So we would encourage you to please come in and work tomorrow, and give us one more day to see if we can work something out. And the next day people came in. And the email went out and said, unfortunately, we were not able to work anything out. So Silver State Mortgage will be closing our doors today.
那是2月14日。电子邮件发出来说，Silver State Mortgage可能要倒闭了，但——是类似这样的事情——可能要倒闭了，但我们认为我们可以想出解决办法。所以我们鼓励你们明天来工作，再给我们一天时间看看能不能想出解决办法。第二天人们来了。电子邮件发出来说，不幸的是，我们没能解决任何问题。所以Silver State Mortgage今天将关门。
And that's how most of these lenders go under. Everybody was working, thinking everything's great, chugging along. And all of a sudden, the bank says, you're done. Then people starting grabbing their computers and their copy machines and rolling them out of the building. It was a mess.
这就是大多数这些贷款机构倒闭的方式。每个人都在工作，认为一切都很棒，进展顺利。突然间，银行说，你完了。然后人们开始抢他们的电脑和复印机，把它们滚出大楼。那是一团糟。
My thoughts were like, holy crap. Everybody's just stealing all their stuff.
我的想法是，该死。每个人都在偷他们的东西。
That happened on February 14?
那是发生在2月14日？
Yep. My boss calls it the Valentine's Day Massacre.
是的。我的老板称之为“情人节大屠杀”。
For Glen Pizzolorusso, the mortgage sales manager who-- not to dwell on this detail-- was living the life of a B-list celebrity, the end came a little more slowly. So you're at WMC. What was the turning point?
对于Glen Pizzolorusso来说，那个——不说这个细节——过着B级名人生活的抵押贷款销售经理，结局来得稍微慢了一点。那么你在WMC。转折点是什么？
I mean this sounds obscene, but I think it was the first month I got a $25,000 paycheck. And at this time, that didn't cover my expenses. So you're sitting here, and you're like, I just made $25,000 this month, which is more than most people make in six months, and it doesn't even cover my expenses. Now what do I do? And then the next couple months I made like $30,000 or $40,000. And then it went down to $10,000. You could just feel it winding down. You knew the good old days were over. And it was scary.
我的意思是这听起来很淫秽，但我认为这是我拿到25000美元工资的第一个月。当时，这甚至不足以覆盖我的开支。所以你坐在这里，想，我这个月刚刚赚了25000美元，这比大多数人六个月赚的还要多，甚至还不够我的开支。现在我该怎么办？接下来的几个月我大概赚了30000或40000美元。然后跌到了10000美元。你就能感觉到它在一点点走低。你知道美好的旧时光已经结束了。这很可怕。
So give me your situation now. Like, can you pay all your bills now?
那么说说你现在的情况。比如，你现在能付清所有的账单吗？
Not really. I borrowed some money from some friends-- well, not-- from my dad. Borrowed some money from Dad. I'm living in my house right now. We're working with the bank to try to avoid foreclosure. At this point, I'm dealing with an attorney. I'm trying to figure out if it makes sense for me to just walk away from the house.
不太能。我从一些朋友那里借了一些钱——嗯，不是——从我爸那里。从老爸那里借了一些钱。我现在住在我自己的房子里。我们正在和银行合作，试图避免止赎。在这个时候，我在处理一个律师的事。我在试图搞清楚我干脆放弃房子是否合理。
And have you been making mortgage payments or not?
你一直在支付抵押贷款吗？
No.
没有。
When was the last time you made a mortgage payment?
你上次支付抵押贷款是什么时候？
January, maybe. And I've been just making them spotty, as I can, just enough to keep them off my back. I mean, I have to watch every penny right now.
一月，大概。我只是断断续续地支付，只要我能，只是为了让他们别来烦我就行。我的意思是，我现在必须盯着每一分钱。
As you can see, this is my living room. I have no furniture in there, because, like I said, it's either buy furniture or pay my mortgage.
如你所见，这是我的客厅。我那里没有家具，因为，就像我说的，要么买家具要么付抵押贷款。
This brings us back to Richard, the marine we met at the very top of the show. He, like more than 4 million Americans at this point, is fighting to keep his home. He's giving me a tour. And I wanted to talk to him about, what now? What happens next, now that the housing bubble has turned into a crisis?
这又把我们带回了我们在节目开头见到的海军陆战队员理查德。他像现在超过400万美国人一样，正在为保住自己的家而奋斗。他正在带我参观。我想和他谈谈，现在怎么办？接下来会发生什么，现在房地产泡沫已经变成了危机？
If he defaults on his mortgage, nobody wins. He doesn't want to leave his house. The investors who own his mortgage, the last thing they want is to own a house in east Flatbush in a declining market with no buyers. So you think it would be easy for both sides to come together and modify Richard's mortgage, figure out something he can afford. You'd be wrong.
如果他抵押贷款违约，没有人是赢家。他不想离开他的家。拥有他抵押贷款的投资者，他们最不想做的事情就是在下跌的市场中拥有一套位于东弗拉特布什、没有买家的房子。所以你以为双方很容易坐下来修改理查德的抵押贷款，弄出他能负担得起的东西。你错了。
Kerry Campbell, nice to meet you. Good, how you doing sir?
Kerry Campbell，很高兴见到你。好的，你好吗先生？
The offices of NACA, the Neighborhood Assistance Corporation of America in Newark, New Jersey are short on frills. Kerry Campbell, who's helping Richard today, is a counselor here. The goal today is to figure out how big a mortgage payment Richard can actually afford to pay. So Kerry needs to know everything Richard spends money on. They go through his medical bills, his clothing budget. Kerry gently nudges Richard to be realistic, like when he asks Richard how much he spends on gifts for his family.
位于新泽西州纽瓦克的美国邻里援助公司（NACA）的办公室没什么花哨的。今天帮助理查德的Kerry Campbell是这里的咨询师。今天目标是弄清楚理查德实际上能负担得起多大的抵押贷款额度。所以Kerry需要知道理查德把钱花在什么地方。他们查看了他的医疗账单、服装预算。Kerry轻声细语地敦促理查德要现实一点，比如当他问理查德花在家人礼物上的钱时。
Gifts for family, how much would you say on average?
给家人的礼物，你平均会说多少？
$300 at Christmas time.
圣诞节时300美元。
January, February-- January through December, Mother's day, Father's day, sisters, brothers, nephews, nieces, significant other, kid's birthday, if you celebrate Christmas-- whole enchilada.
一月、二月——从一月到十二月，母亲节，父亲节，姐妹，兄弟，侄子，侄女，另一半，孩子的生日，如果你过圣诞节——全套服务。
Let's say $1,000.
就算1000美元吧。
That sounds about right.
听起来差不多。
The process we're doing right now, how does this compare to when you bought the house?
我们现在正在做的这个流程，和你买房时相比怎么样？
This is totally different. It's brand new to me. But when I bought my house it was just your credit score and can I pull a credit report?
这完全不同。对我来说是全新的。但当我买房时，只是你的信用评分和能不能拉出一份信用报告？
So in this whole process, what's the first time someone looked at your finances?
那么在整个过程中，这是第一次有人看你的财务状况吗？
Today. Today.
今天。今天。
Not to say the original broker didn't have a process. It just had nothing to do with reality. Kerry shows Richard the loan documents filled out when he bought the house by his original broker.
并不是说原来的经纪人没有流程。它只是与现实毫无关系。Kerry向理查德展示了当初购房时他的原经纪人填写的贷款文件。
Here it's saying your base employment income was $16,250 a month.
这里说你的基本就业收入是每月16250美元。
What?
什么？
$16,250 a month, which means your salary on a yearly basis would be making-- you're making just under $200,000, $195,000 to be exact.
每月16250美元，这意味着你按年计算的薪水将是——你赚的不到20万美元，准确地说是195000美元。
I wish. In 2005-- and they used my 2005 taxes-- I was making $37,000 a year.
我希望。2005年——他们使用了我2005年的税单——我一年赚37000美元。
Did you know that number until now?
你直到现在才知道那个数字吗？
No.
不。
So he stated $16,000 a month. To me, that is shocking. To you, it's not that shocking?
所以他声明每月16000美元。对我来说，这太令人震惊了。对你来说，没那么震惊吗？
Oh, that's outrageous. But it's a common thing. There's worlds apart from the reality and what's on a lot of these documents.
噢，那太离谱了。但这是常见的事。现实和这些文件上的内容有着天壤之别。
Another thing the papers reveal, how much that creative broker made, $18,500. As Kerry says, that's 18,000 reasons to falsify Richards mortgage documents and to put him in a house he can't afford.
文件显示的另一件事，那个有创意的经纪人赚了多少钱，18500美元。正如Kerry所说，那是伪造理查德抵押贷款文件并把他塞进一所他负担不起的房子的18000个理由。
Richard actually qualified for a Veterans Administration Loan at a really good rate. And he had money to put down. But the broker convinced him to take a mortgage that turned out to be much worse, but did have a much higher commission.
理查德实际上有资格以非常好的利率获得退伍军人管理局贷款。而且他有首付款。但经纪人说服他申请了一笔结果要糟糕得多的抵押贷款，但确实有高得多的佣金。
Mortgage brokers were walking around east Flatbush knocking on doors, telling just about anybody, hey, we can get you a house. If you have a house, we can get you a big home equity line of credit. This happened in poor neighborhoods all over the country.
抵押贷款经纪人走在东弗拉特布什，敲门，告诉几乎任何人，嘿，我们可以给你弄套房子。如果你有房子，我们可以给你一大笔房屋净值信贷额度。这种情况发生在全国各地的贫困社区。
And while the FBI and other law enforcement folks say they don't have the exact numbers, it's clear that fraud, like that fraud on Richard's application, was ubiquitous.
虽然联邦调查局和其他执法人员说他们没有确切的数字，但很明显，欺诈，就像理查德申请表上的那种欺诈，是无处不在的。
At the end of Richard's budget process, the math they come up with is fairly stark. Richard makes more money now. He got a new and better job. So he makes an average, before taxes, of $8,000 a month. Which means after taxes he brings home exactly enough to pay his mortgage and nothing else. All of his living expenses he says, are paid with money he gets from his mom, who is on public assistance, his girlfriend, and his brother.
理查德预算流程结束时，他们得出的数字相当严峻。理查德现在的收入增加了。他得到了一份新且更好的工作。所以他平均扣税前每月赚8000美元。这意味着扣税后他带回家的钱刚好够支付抵押贷款，什么都不剩。他所有的生活费用他说都是靠他妈妈——靠公共援助生活——、他的女朋友和他的兄弟给的钱支付的。
Kerry runs the software, which says that if Richard is going to stay in his house, he needs a much cheaper mortgage. The interest, which is currently at around 10%, would have to be lowered a lot, to 3%.
Kerry运行了软件，显示如果理查德要留在他的房子里，他需要一笔便宜得多的抵押贷款。利息，目前在10%左右，必须大幅降低，降到3%。
Kerry wants to propose this to whoever owns the loan, but this brings him to this peculiar problem mortgage owners face now. They have no idea who that is. Richard's loan has been bought, and sold, and resold, and put into one of those pools owned by investors, maybe an investor like Jim Finkel.
Kerry想向拥有贷款的任何人提出这个建议，但这把他带到了抵押贷款所有者现在面临的这个特殊问题上。他们根本不知道那是谁。理查德的贷款已经被买入、卖出、再卖出，并被放入了投资者拥有的那些池子之一，也许是像Jim Finkel那样的投资者。
150 times was it 3,000-- let's be conservative?
150次，那是3000——我们保守一点？
So, now we're back in Jim Finkel's office. He is surrounded by very expensive computers, but he's typing on a cheap calculator. And he's trying to figure out for us how many individual mortgages, how many homes like Richard's, does he and his company own a part of. The calculator method soon fails him, and he turns to one of his number crunchers, a guy named Alex.
所以，现在我们又回到了Jim Finkel的办公室。他被非常昂贵的电脑包围着，但他正在使用一个廉价计算器。他试图为我们弄清楚，他和他的公司拥有多少个人抵押贷款，多少像理查德这样的房子。计算器的方法很快让他失败，他求助于他的数字分析专家之一，一个叫Alex的家伙。
I can't even imagine-- Alex, do you have any idea?
我简直无法想象——Alex，你有什么头绪吗？
Alex gets on the phone with Steve, the IT guy.
Alex给IT人员Steve打了电话。
How many loans are you running in loan performance, altogether? For all of our deals, how many loans, individual mortgage loans? 16 million loans?
你在贷款表现中一共运行了多少笔贷款？对于我们所有的交易，有多少笔，个人抵押贷款？1600万笔贷款？
This one CDO factory, this one office, owns a share of 16 million homes. And each of these homes has lots of other owners, people in other CDO offices around the world-- there are lots of them-- and other investors. You start to see what a crazy web of confusing interconnections this whole process is. Now until this moment, we had a theory that the homeowners and the people on the other end, the people at the top of the chain--
这个CDO工厂，这个办公室，拥有1600万套房子的份额。而这些房子中的每一套都有很多其他所有者，世界上其他CDO办公室的人——有很多——还有其他投资者。你开始看到整个过程是一个多么疯狂的令人困惑的相互连接的网络。直到这一刻，我们有一个理论，房主和另一端的人，链条顶端的人——
The investors--
投资者——
The investors like Jim Finkel--
像Jim Finkel这样的投资者——
That they had no idea about each other.
他们彼此之间一无所知。
Right, but we actually learned that they know quite a lot about each other. They just see each other through a computer screen.
对，但我们实际上了解到他们对彼此了解很多。他们只是通过电脑屏幕看到对方。
Hey, Steve.
嘿，Steve。
Hey, what's going on?
嘿，发生什么事了？
We find that out when we go downstairs to see Steve Pennington, the IT guy. Steve's actual title is head of financial engineering. He's created his own software program that actually looks at every one of the 16 million loans Dynamic owns part of. It's a spreadsheet. Each line is one loan. And it has all sorts of information like how much the house sold for, what the interest rate is. He points to one field, which is the most baffling one. It's just a cell on a spreadsheet. And it just has 12 letters and numbers in a row. Every letter represents a month.
当我们下楼去见IT人员Steve Pennington时，我们发现了这一点。Steve的实际头衔是金融工程主管。他创建了自己的软件程序，实际上查看了Dynamic拥有的1600万笔贷款中的每一笔。这是一个电子表格。每一行是一笔贷款。它有各种各样的信息，比如房子卖了多少钱，利率是多少。他指着一个栏位，这是最令人费解的一个。它只是电子表格上的一个单元格。它连续有12个字母和数字。每个字母代表一个月。
What does the nine mean?
那个9意味着什么？
It means they are 90 days of, basically, delinquent on their loan.
意味着他们基本上在贷款上逾期90天了。
So is this the Matrix , where the guy's looking at the green digits passing. And he's saying, oh there's the redhead, there's the blond? Are you, Steve, seeing lives here?
所以这是《黑客帝国》吗，那家伙看着绿色数字掠过。他说，噢，那里有红发女郎，那里有金发女郎？Steve，你在看着这里的生命吗？
I definitely see lives.
我确实看到了生命。
Especially when you look at this here, this thing here? That's to me, the most vivid.
尤其是当你看到这个时，这个东西在这里？对我来说，这是最生动的。
Just for the record, I see a bunch of-- CCCCC3636CC-- I do not see a human drama.
记录在案，我看到了一堆——CCCCC3636CC——我没有看到人类的戏剧。
The drama here, is you've got someone who's been paying their loan, and then something's happened. And then they've gone three months delinquent, three months delinquent, six months delinquent, and then three months. So they basically got to this point of  six, and then they fought back the current.
这里的戏剧是，你有一个一直按时还贷的人，然后发生了什么事情。然后他们逾期了三个月，逾期了三个月，逾期了六个月，然后是三个月。所以他们基本上到了六这个点，然后他们反抗了电流。
Now that I've learned the code, now that you've taught me the code, I see it. Like here, he was on time for a bunch of months. Then he went 30 days, 30 days, 30 days. Then he went two months behind. Then he came back. And now he seems to--
现在我已经学会了代码，现在你教了我代码，我看到了。比如这里，他连续几个月准时还款。然后他逾期了30天，30天，30天。然后他落后了两个月。然后他回来了。现在他似乎——
Right, what's really hard about this is then you watch people-- you can watch over these 12 months, people cycle on and off.
对，这真的很困难，因为你看着人们——你可以在这12个月里看着人们进进出出。
You guys are much more sympathetic. And it might be just because we're reporters, and you want to make us think you're good guys, but you're really cold-hearted.
你们这群人更有同情心。也许只是因为我们是记者，而你想让我们认为你们是好人，但你们真的铁石心肠。
We're human beings.
我们是人类。
These guys are hurting you. Their irresponsibility is costing you money and work.
这些人正在伤害你。他们的不负责任正在耗费你们的金钱和精力。
That was up to us to think about three years ago.
那是三年前我们需要考虑的事情。
Do you have any anger when you look at this?
当你看着这个时，你有任何愤怒吗？
No, not at all. This is pure sadness.
不，完全没有。这纯粹是悲伤。
This is where the partnership of borrowers like Clarence Nathan and investors liked Jim Finkel has ended up. Tonko Gast estimates that most of the AAA rated mortgage-backed CDOs that the industry created since 2006 are now worth less than half their value. Some are worth close to 0.
这就是像Clarence Nathan这样的借款人和像Jim Finkel这样的投资者之间的伙伴关系的最终结局。Tonko Gast估计，自2006年以来该行业创造的大多数AAA评级的抵押贷款支持CDO现在价值不足其价值的一半。有些价值接近于0。
But remember, to all the investment managers in the global pool of money who bought them AAA meant safe as government bonds. AAA was called a cash equivalent, money in the bank.
但记住，对于所有购买它们的全球资金池的投资经理来说，AAA意味着像政府债券一样安全。AAA被称为现金等价物，银行里的钱。
It's as if the global pool of money put trillions of dollars in a savings account, came back one year later, and found out that half the money was gone. Or put another way, it's as if the global pool of money thought it was putting trillions of dollars in a savings account, but really half of it was going into a furnace. The money is gone, burned up, never to come back. And that has led to a new term you've been hearing.
就好像全球资金池把数万亿美元放在了储蓄账户里，一年后回来，发现一半的钱不见了。或者换句话说，就好像全球资金池以为它把数万亿美元放在了储蓄账户里，但实际上有一半进入了火炉。钱没了，烧光了，再也回不来了。这导致了一个你一直在听到的新词。
Yeah, maybe you've noticed that the press and others don't call it a sub-prime housing crisis as much. They're now calling it a credit crisis. The global pool of money still has no idea how much money they lost, how much went into the furnace. And because of that, they've totally changed their thinking.
是的，也许你已经注意到媒体和其他人不再称之为次贷住房危机了。他们现在称之为信贷危机。全球资金池仍然不知道他们损失了多少钱，有多少进了火炉。正因为如此，他们完全改变了思维方式。
They used to be obsessed just with getting some kind of profit, any higher interest rate return. Now the global pool of money has the exact opposite obsession. It wants no risk whatsoever. It just wants safety. Suddenly, those US government treasury bonds-- still near the historic lows of 1% and 2%-- are beautifully attractive because they're safe. They will never blow up like sub-prime CDOs did.
他们过去沉迷于获得某种利润，任何更高的利息回报。现在全球资金池有着完全相反的痴迷。它不想要任何风险。它只想要安全。突然间，那些美国政府国债——仍然接近1%和2%的历史低点——变得非常迷人，因为它们很安全。它们永远不会像次贷CDO那样炸掉。
The global pool of money is avoiding anything with even the slightest hint of risk. And that affects everybody, no matter who you are. It's harder to borrow money to buy a house, or build a factory, or bring your country boldly into the 21st century.
全球资金池正在规避任何有一丁点风险的东西。这影响了每个人，无论你是谁。借钱买房、建工厂或大胆地将你的国家带入21世纪变得更加困难。
Take Iceland. A year ago, it was easy for them to borrow billions. Now they're seen as too risky. Their central bank has to pay more than 15% interest to get anyone to loan them money. They could do better putting their national debt on a credit card. Hungary, Kazakhstan, Turkey, they are all in similar situations.
看看冰岛。一年前，他们借贷数十亿很容易。现在他们被视为风险太高。他们的中央银行必须支付超过15%的利息才能让任何人借钱给他们。他们用信用卡支付国家债务可能会做得更好。匈牙利、哈萨克斯坦、土耳其，他们都处于类似的情况。
You might have heard about problems in student lending. Companies that needed credit to survive are shutting down. The US expects more than 1.1 million bankruptcies this year, twice the 2006 number.
你可能听说过学生贷款的问题。需要信贷才能生存的公司正在倒闭。美国预计今年将有超过110万宗破产案，是2006年的两倍。
This freezing of credit all around the world is something new. The world has never seen anything on this scale. When the crisis hit last August, central bankers and finance economists couldn't figure out just how bad things might get. There is this question people would ask, will things get like the 1930s or the 1970s?
这种全球范围内的信贷冻结是新的。世界从未见过这种规模的事情。当危机在去年八月爆发时，中央银行家和金融经济学家们无法确定事情会变得多糟。人们会问这个问题，事情会变得像1930年代或1970年代吗？
There's a real fear that just like in the '30s, hundreds of banks would collapse. There would be massive unemployment. There was talk of a new, Great Depression.
有一种真实的恐惧，就像在30年代一样，数百家银行会倒闭。会有大规模失业。有人谈论一场新的、大萧条。
That talk seems to have faded. And there's more talk that the next few years will feel like the 1970s. There are lots of technical differences between this crisis and Jimmy Carter's malaise. But for the average person it could feel the same. It's not an out-and-out depression. Everything's just kind of crappy. And not just in housing and banking, but for the economy as a whole. It's barely growing. There aren't a lot of new businesses, new jobs, unemployment keeps creeping up. We're just sort of stuck in neutral for a while. Anyone under, say, 45 probably doesn't remember that 1970s malaise too well. Anyone under 30 has barely known a US economy that wasn't growing. Now, there's a decent chance we'll all get to see what life felt like in the '70s, which isn't great. It's pretty bad, actually, unless you're comparing it to the 1930s.
那种谈论似乎已经淡化了。现在有更多的讨论说未来几年会感觉像1970年代。这次危机与Jimmy Carter时代的萎靡不振之间有很多技术差异。但对于普通人来说，感觉可能是一样的。那不是彻底的萧条。一切只是有点糟糕。不仅在房地产和银行业，而且对整个经济而言。它几乎没有增长。没有很多新企业、新工作，失业率不断攀升。我们只是有一段时间被困在空档里。任何45岁以下的人可能不太记得那个1970年代的萎靡不振。任何30岁以下的人几乎没经历过不增长的美国经济。现在，我们所有人都有很大的机会看到1970年代的生活是什么感觉，那并不好。实际上非常糟糕，除非你是拿它和1930年代相比。
Alex Blumberg and Adam Davidson. Alex, my voice is so bad, I think maybe you should read the credits. Why don't you do it?
Alex Blumberg和Adam Davidson。Alex，我的嗓子太糟糕了，我想也许你应该读一下制作人员名单。为什么不你来呢？
All right, Ira. I hope you feel better. I'm going to bring Adam in here to help me to, since I've never done this before.
好的，Ira。希望你感觉好些。我要把Adam带进来帮我，因为我以前从没做过这个。
Thanks today to Ellen Weiss at NPR who made this collaboration happen this week between the news division at NPR, where I work, All Things Considered , and This American Life .
感谢今天NPR的Ellen Weiss，是她促成了本周我工作的NPR新闻部、《All Things Considered》和《This American Life》之间的这次合作。
Where I work. Thanks also to Mary Ann Casavant, Anna Chai, Kevin Byers, the fantastic housing blog, Calculated Risk , Alexis Grenell, Stephanie Cohen Glass, Sanjeev Handa, Charlie Ledley, James Scurlock, Chris Turpin, Elaine Glick, Mark [? Adelson, ?] Dan Naygrow.
我工作的地方。还要感谢Mary Ann Casavant、Anna Chai、Kevin Byers，精彩的住房博客《Calculated Risk》，Alexis Grenell、Stephanie Cohen Glass、Sanjeev Handa、Charlie Ledley、James Scurlock、Chris Turpin、Elaine Glick、Mark [? Adelson, ?] Dan Naygrow。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight--
WBEZ管理监督——
No, I want to do this one.
不，我想做这个。
OK, here you go.
好的，给你。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Ira's boss Mr. Torey Malatia. He and Ira go out at night sometimes together. It's pretty chill. Torey describes it like this--
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督，由Ira的老板Torey Malatia先生负责。他和Ira有时晚上会一起出去。很酷。Torey是这样描述的——
You know, we order probably three or four bottles of Cristal at a $1,000 a bottle. Everybody's like, whoa, who's the cool guys?
你知道，我们大概点三四瓶水晶香槟，一瓶1000美元。每个人都像，哇，那是谁的酷哥？
I'm not Ira Glass.
我不是Ira Glass。
I'm not either.
我也不是。
But we will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
但我们下周会回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。